acclaimed chef Jason Atherton has
restaurants the world over but he got
his start close to home
born in England he started cooking at
the age of 12 in the seaside hotel run
by his family at 16 he ran away to
London and got a job at a
michelin-starred restaurant all while
living in a youth hostel after years
working under prominent chefs he began
building his own global restaurant
empire first in London and later in Hong
Kong Shanghai Sydney and Dubai two years
ago he came across the pond and made a
huge splash his first American
restaurant the clock tower was an
instant hit and a must visit venue on
the new york dining scene Chef Jason
Atherton welcome to the dish thank you
for having me and what a great looking
table this is tell us what we got here
well we got some some my favorites so
I've got barbecue baked beans mmm
Brooklyn burrata tomato salad with some
fresh olives a lovely New York Strip
that's beautiful any of them nice like
mixed salad and then we've got some
heritage carrots just roasted in the
beef fat and then sticky toffee pudding
made to finish and then duck fat triple
cooked chips amazing and what's our
cocktail here Deal or No Deal so this is
our this is our famous cocktail he's
come down a storm here in the clock
tower we can't take it off the menu
because everyone goes nuts it's a big
success in London we were doing it so
he's got gin local gin and it's got sin
gmm which is like a elderflower liqueur
and then fresh cucumber steeped and then
some fresh dill is done very nice when
you think about your career and food it
you know it's sort of in your blood to a
certain degree right her family was in
the industry you know how tell us about
that experience growing up in that
environment well I mean they weren't
quite michelin-starred it was a tiny
little seaside town called Skegness in
in Lincolnshire on the on the East Coast
very popular in the 70s when I was
growing up for Holi makers and they had
a tiny little guest house where you
would have bed and breakfast and you
word around just come and stay stay for
the weekend working with this very
English and then you know you would have
high tea and you'd have breakfast and
that would be it then you'd be on your
way and so mum would make everything
fresh and my sister would have to help
after school before school and slay the
tables clear wash up that time and so so
hospitality was always in our blood you
know how did mom feel when you ran away
basically she was mortified now I've got
11 year old daughter I actually should
get it bad I get it and she's like five
years away from running away from home
I'll be like and I'm like the police
hunting her down you know so but I was
so desperate to become a great chef and
I knew being in the north thing there
was no great restaurants back there so I
had to get to London you know I had to
all cast so I just mom and dad went to
Spain in the winter break yeah so sister
was supposed to be looking after me and
I just said look you know I'm out of
here
you studied you mentioned Spain you
studied with some of the greats Ferran
adrià Gordon Ramsay what did you learn
from them well you know I was very lucky
to be bygone side for 11 years on when
he was on his meteoric climb playing to
fame if you like and when he first won
three Michelin stars and went on to be
the shoot success story is in America
today and then with fran Adria I learned
it was about creativity
you know there's I still believe today
he's the most creative chef who's ever
lived you know and I think it will be
for some time because he doesn't think
about food like we think about but yeah
yeah it's tom is completely different
you know it was like insane to spend 18
months in that kitchen down in Ross
house when he was at his peak
what's that how do you run the 17
restaurants around oh I don't I'm very
looking at we have a head office in in
Soho in central London what my wife runs
with a huge team of people from accounts
to all that type of stuff and then each
the way I do it is it's quite simple
each restaurant I open I have a chef
business partner yep so he's normally
one of my second-in-command I'm making
my partner me and my wife give him a
share of the business he then runs it as
his own we help secret the secret to the
success is what you know what seriously
hard work dedication be true to your
customers make sure that everybody who
walks with that door is treated like a
king and if you really care and a
passionate about what you do and don't
do it for like money or fame or anything
like that people get it you know and
they just come to your Russian because
they you know it's that I was just
cooking up clocked out overnight and
some guess that's about come up and
speak to and they were like you know
what you're doing such a great job here
and we love you
wine that's so great here it's still in
the kitchen and unusual for Somerset
lunch and dinner chef as I asked you to
sign this dish part of the ritual here
on the dish I'll ask you the question we
ask all visiting chefs judges if you
could share this meal with any person
past or present who would it be
I mean I'm so fortunate to have a very
supportive wife I don't see much or as
much as I'd like to so I know it's a
little bit cliche but I'd have to spend
it with my wife and my two beautiful
children who I miss dearly when I'm
traveling and stuff so that would that
would be you're gonna get points for
that cliche but it's a smart answer
yes very smart chef Jason Atherton thank
you